[Música]
bem vindos a bordo em 1984 eu e meu
marido wilfredo tínhamos um sonho que
começamos a realizar era dar a volta ao
mundo em um veleiro e começamos o nosso
sonho contra tudo e contra todos
imagina todas as pessoas chegavam
perguntavam qual é o seu maior desafio
no mar e tempestades piratas
o triângulo das bermudas e eu vou
confessar para vocês
o maior desafio pra mim foi educar os
meus filhos a bordo do veleiro mas
lógico nós nos preparamos durante dez
anos pra poder sair largar para trás a
nossa casa o nosso trabalho e colocar
dentro de um barco pequeno os nossos
três filhos nós os tiramos da escola
para levar conosco e nós vivemos o nosso
sonho
na ocasião o pr tinha 15 anos
o davi 10 anos e ouviu a 17 anos
gente o que eu escutei da família dos
amigos horrorizados
coitadinhos você vai levar eles um barco
pra andar ao redor do mundo que vão sem
essas crianças
eles vão ser totalmente o boom do mar
eles não têm escola e você como
professora
que desastre vai ser eu olhava pra todos
eles e dizia esse é o nosso sonho é isso
que a gente quer fazer e eu tinha muita
confiança na minha vontade de ser a
professora dos meus filhos
bom colocamos nossos filhos dentro do
barco e comecei a dar aulas para eles
mas de todos os materiais
acho que eu comecei a ensinar ele eu
também aprendi uma que foi fundamental
na educação desses meus filhos
disciplina
eles eram mestres de quando a gente
encorajava um lugar bonito aquele mar de
águas azuis aquelas praias de areias
brancas
eles diziam olha que legal vamos fazer o
seguinte a gente estuda depois vamos
sair vamos nadar
vamos explorar esse lugar e depois a
gente faz aula e eudes lembra que a
gente combinou que nossas aulas vêm em
primeiro lugar e depois explorar em
segundo mas à medida que a gente foi
navegando eu fui descobrindo que eu
podia quebrar as paredes da sala de aula
em 1984 gente sem tv sem celular sem
mais fácil à internet
colocamos um mês copérdia inteira e
cheio de livros debaixo das nossas camas
os nossos beliches e à medida que a
gente foi navegando eu tive um
privilégio que nenhum outro professor no
mundo teve eu pude ensinar aos meus
filhos em bloco por exemplo quem é que
tem esse privilégio de ensinar sobre
vulcões ao redor de uma cratera bem
olhando pra dentro eu tive em galápagos
com eles e eles aprenderam na teoria da
evolução das espécies
aonde down em descobriu o desenvolveu
essa mesma teoria nadar ao lado das
baleias e dos golfinhos ciências a
cadeia alimentar dos peixes
e aí a geografia a história foi
crescendo à sala de aula ao meu redor
junto com esses meus alunos sempre
atentos e eles também foram
desenvolvendo uma espécie de auto de
batismo eles viam que quando estamos
três dias navegando é dias de chuva eles
podiam adiantar os deveres eles podiam
ainda adiantar os trabalhos
ler mais
e com isso eles tinham lá na frente um
dia ou dois de folga então ao mesmo
tempo que os meus filhos começaram a
viajar e veleja nós também nos
preocupamos com a sociabilidade deles e
quando eles começaram a socializar com
todas as crianças com os meninos dos
outros barcos com as crianças em terra
e foi assim que tiveram experiências
incríveis em tonga seja imaginar o
mandar seus filhos adolescentes de 13 e
15 anos da escola de saia
foi exatamente isso que aconteceu era a
vestimenta chama lava para eles foi uma
experiência incrível e pra mim foi uma
experiência maior ainda
então nós fomos acumulando essas
experiências junto da nossa vida a bordo
eu tive um aprendizado muito grande com
eles mais do que eu ensinei eu aprendia
e quando eles cresceram eles começaram a
cada um deles escolher a sua vida o seu
sonho e foi assim que o pierre o mais
velho com 18 anos desembarca nos estados
unidos e foi estudar administração
o deivid o segundo filho ele resolveu
ficar na nova zelândia
eu fiquei no barco david ficou lá na
terra naquele porto e eu olhava cada vez
que o barco e afastando ele foi
diminuindo de tamanho foi ficando
pequenininho até que desapareceu
meu coração quase para o chorei dois
dias de emoção você deixar os seus
filhos crescerem e buscar os sonhos
deles também e deve ficou na nova
zelândia para estudar cinema e televisão
eo vilson o nosso menor durante dez anos
viveu no barco ele decidir que a sua
profissão seria de windsor fita
profissional e assim cada um deles
dentro da sua profissão seguiu a sua
carreira ea nossa vida
imagina todos os filhos criados de
repente
mudou muito nós conhecemos
em 1992 o casal robert neozelandês ea
giane uma brasileira uma filhinha
pequena a qat e nós nos tornamos amigos
ali na nova zelândia e durante algum
tempo que convivemos juntos e quando
saímos da nova zelândia e chegamos no
brasil 1995
me veio robert carregando a qat no colo
e nós olhamos e perguntamos como é cadê
a sua esposa a giane e ele nos comunicou
ali
regiane tinha falecido de aids
perante a nossa surpresa ele contou que
em 1989 ela havia sofrido um acidente de
automóvel e foi atropelada e teve que
fazer uma cirurgia no qual tomou várias
bolsas de sangue numa transfusão e
algumas delas ou uma delas estava
infectada com o vírus do hiv
e ele era soropositivo e ketty também
ali naquele momento reatamos aquela
amizade parecia que nem tinha passado
mais de três anos e quando um belo dia
nós estamos conversando
roberto voltou pra conversar conosco e
ele disse eu queria falar uma coisa para
vocês eu estou mal eu não sei quanto
tempo eu vou viver
eu queria que a minha filha não ficar
sozinha eu queria que ela tivesse uma
família como eu vi que vocês criaram
seus filhos
eu queria que vocês adotassem a cast eu
olhei pro wilfredo wilfredo olhou pra
mim e de repente eu olhei pra qat e
quando eu vi o sorriso naquela criança
os olhinhos curiosos
eu já sabia que eu era a mãe dela
e foi assim que kate veio a viver
conosco no barco e se tornou a nossa
jovem marinheira
bom dia pra mim o desafio maior da qat
lógico que tinham todos os cuidados com
a saúde mas era uma alegria terá qat
junto conosco ela gostava de cantar
curiosa perguntava tudo e ela tinha
somente três anos quando gasquet fez
cinco anos nós saímos pra fazer uma
segunda volta ao mundo ea nossa mala
lente marinheira foi junto e ela gostava
de explorar de conhecer os lugares e ela
falava sempre puxa eu sou a maior
aventureira vamos pra aventura era a
primeira se levantar e nos convidar para
fazer aventuras e aí eu voltei a ser
professora dessa vez com uma linha só
essa minha luna e usou o mesmo método do
que seus irmãos da causa diz coamari
cana já estava numa outra fase já estava
na fase em que tinha internet que tinha
computador que tinha cds
então assim pra mim também foi um novo
aprendizado e ketty estudou aproveitou
todas as aventuras que vivemos durante
dois anos e três meses nessa viagem e
assim quer cresceu e quando nós voltamos
ao brasil
kath teve que freqüentar uma escola e aí
ela dizia que bom eu vou fazer
amiguinhas que bom eu vou conhecer mais
outras crianças e assim qat foi para a
escola e quando ela chegou na escola era
maior alegria dela e ketty devido a
problemas com sua saúde é não crescia
como todas as outras crianças ela tinha
uma estatura mais baixa para as crianças
da cidade e também ela andava diferente
meio que cambaleante
às vezes ela brincava dizia eu ando que
nem um pinguim e ela fazia brincadeira
mas quando ela chegou na escola onde ela
veio pra mim e perguntou me o que é
deficiente e eu não soube responder eu
falei pô
as crianças me chama de deficiente mas
eu sei
lê em inglês eu sei falar espanhol
eu sei em português eu sei brincar eu
sei e ciências
eu já nadei eu já andei de caiaque eu já
beijei um golfinho e ela começou a
contar de todas as deficiências de que
ela era capaz e aí foi quando eu me dei
conta que o aprendizado da cash na
escola era mais do que as matérias
didáticas eram mais do que as lições que
ela tinha que aprender qat adorava
estudar e ela tinha uma capacidade de
liderança gente era uma pequena gigante
ela organizava sua turma de trabalho de
equipe colocava todo mundo junto e fazer
a apresentação do trabalho à medida que
ela foi crescendo ou não crescendo ela
começou a ser discriminada e sofreu de
bullying porque as meninas deixaram de
convidá-lo para as festinhas a você não
tem namorado você uma criancinha
você nem usa sutiã e ketty olhava e
falava comigo mas não tem nada de errado
eu sou mais menino igual a elas eu tenho
a mesma idade e foi aí que eu aprendi a
maior lição que uma professora tem que
aprender a lição do amor incondicional
não importa do jeito que é quem é quando
essa criança vem pra você você tem que
aceitar e fazer com que essa criança
seja aceita e ketty era alto motivada
ela dizia pra mim eu vou conseguir ela
tem no diário dela uma frase que diz
assim eu vou mostrar aquelas emitidas do
que eu sou capaz então ela era melhor
aluna ela se esforçavam o máximo pra
poder é não mostrar para todos nós para
ela mesmo do que era capaz e ketty
adorava se
dizia quando eu crescer eu vou ser uma
cientista então era todas as
oportunidades que tinham fora da escola
vamos visitar uma exposição sobre
dinossauros vamos visitar uma galeria de
arte tudo eram motivos pra qat aprender
e ela desenvolveu o seu aprendizado e
ketty também tinha uma coisa maravilhosa
ela era uma ferrenha defensora da
natureza e ela dizia porque as pessoas
jogam lixo no mar não sabe que os
golfinhos vão comer o as tartarugas vou
morrer com plástico e eu dizia pra ela
você tem que fazer alguma coisa você tem
que ajudar a natureza e ela se tornou
também mergulhadora enfim ela cresceu e
viveu a sua vida intensamente ela passou
este amor à natureza para as pessoas que
estavam ao seu redor fez projetos pra
poder ajudar a natureza e assim qat
cresceu e eu fui aprendendo essas lições
de que além de ser mãe eu era uma
professora
junto com o qat eu sou uma navegadora
autora é e além de disso tudo
aventureira
mas basicamente essencialmente antes de
tudo eu sou uma educadora uma professora
e sempre nas melhores maneiras possíveis
tentei ensinar aos meus filhos
inclusive todos eles com a cats a se
motivar a descobrir a ter a curiosidade
que é o elemento mais importante na vida
de uma criança de um jovem descobre você
mesmo procura a resposta
e aí eu falo para vocês fiquei muito
orgulhosa quando o meu filho me disse
depois de adulto disse pra mim
mami eu vou dizer uma coisa você nos
ensinou a fome do saber
e quando eu escutei isso e vendo os meus
filhos hoje adultos
eu perguntei a mim mesmo não existe um
processo certo de aprendizado mas existe
um processo certo de amor ao aprendizado
e com isso eu quero dizer pra vocês deu
certo o que aconteceu os coitadinhos
nossa os vagabundos do mar o que foi que
ele se tornará um bom gr meu filho de 48
anos é o fundador e o senhor da
bossa-nova investimento que é a maior
empresa de investimentos está
rapidamente rica latina
deivid obrigado
davi aos 42 anos é cineasta estudou na
nova zelândia e se formou em cinema e
televisão e o seu filme o pequeno
segredo foi indicado a representar o
brasil no oscar em 2016 e viu ham o
nosso caçula
depois de passar dez anos no mar já
escolheu a sua profissão no des portes
trouxe mais de 100 títulos para o brasil
sendo que cinco títulos de campeão
mundial e hoje é o nosso segundo capitão
a bordo do barco
então gente o que eu tenho a dizer pra
vocês é que a educação deles pra mim deu
certo e ketty a nossa pequena marinheira
seguiu o seu caminho
ela está navegando em mares
além do horizonte e partiu em 2006
vítima da do vírus do hiv mas ela deixou
para nós
o ensinamento do amor incondicional ea
luz que ilumina os nossos caminhos e os
nossos sonhos
muito obrigado pregão
brandão